we often make the mistake of thinking
that the said principle specific
adaptations to impose demands doesn't
apply to endurance but let me ask you
this who will be better equipped to dig
a hole for ten hours straight a marathon
runner or a farmer the answer is
obviously the farmer likewise if you
want to fight for longer without getting
gassed out then running might not be the
best or most optimal use of your time
there is more to endurance than simply
your aerobic capacity and even aerobic
capacity is more multifaceted than you
think firstly there are peripheral
adaptations that occur as well as
systemic ones when you engage in any
form of cardio case-in-point your
lactate threshold this is the point at
which your body is forced to switch from
a predominantly anaerobic energy system
to a predominantly aerobic one the point
at which you're forced to back off
before you start vomiting this is
different depending on the activity of
your engaging in swimming for example
uses different muscles than running
those different muscles have different
ratios of slow to fast twitch muscle
fibers which in turn means they produce
differing amounts of hydrogen ions when
you swim regularly changes will occur in
the muscle that affects that ratio
likewise it'll also increase the
efficiency in the number of mitochondria
other changes will occur around the
muscle team for instance training with
repetitive contractions this way will
increase the number of blood vessels
supplying blood to the muscles your
circulatory system is rewiring itself to
be able to send more blood to the areas
where it's needed
likewise you'll see an increase in
glycogen storage making energy more
readily available to those muscles and
did you know that your muscles can even
contribute to circulation specifically
the muscle pump system describes how
contracting large muscles actually
increases the pressure in embedded
peripheral veins bear by aiding venous
return sending blood back to the heart
squeezing it back
in other words strengthening different
muscle groups may improve your
circulation effectively giving you many
more hearts located throughout your body
check out the excellent book beyond
training by Ben Greenfield for more on
this so if you want to improve your
endurance for tennis you might find that
combining endurance training that
focuses on the upper body and the lower
body such as rowing and running would be
more effective than just running most
effective of all though would be lots of
tennis what's more though is that
training that specifically focuses on
muscle can
two actions over time might actually
have useful crossover for endurance in
particular the use of quasi isometrics
that's very slow movements and very long
yielding isometrics that's completely
static holds might be useful for
encouraging adaptations that allow for
prolonged use of that muscle
counter-intuitively standing completely
still in a lunge might help you to run
faster for longer the same also goes for
bodybuilding style higher rep ranges the
target so-called sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy there are significant
cardiac benefits to this kind of
training personally I incorporate cardio
into my workouts by performing finishers
at the end of the session that somewhat
mimic the strength training I did at the
beginning in other words if I was doing
a lot of bench presses that I might end
with a quasi isometric pushup or super
high rep push-ups if I was trading the
shoulders and triceps though then I
might end with some heavy bag work or
battle ropes finally this also makes a
great case for circuits and metcon
workouts that involve multiple stations
this is a form of cardio that uses
insufficient recovery times to keep the
heart rate elevated but by switching
between movements you create a
formidable and adaptable form of
endurance they'll prepare you for
anything add some resistance cardio or
plyometrics to that routine with a
kettlebell swing or something similar
and you just made your training all the
more effective depending on your
intended goals by using fast twitch
muscle fiber you ensure that you're
using the anaerobic system that would be
necessary for lots of explosive sports
and you avoid the conversion to slow
twitch fiber
of course if endurance events are what
you're training for then you don't need
to add extra load or explosiveness for
the super function 8 use both kinds Plus
this also develops your ability to
shuttle blood quickly from one part of
the body to another
this shunting effect increases the
demand on your cardiovascular system
even more which is why the most grueling
circuits will alternate between upper
body and lower body movements
on top of the local adaptations to
endurance there is also a significant
difference in training that targets
different energy systems I've already
discussed in previous videos the
difference between low intensity
steady-state cardio like running long
distances and high intensity interval
training to cut a long story short hit
training has many advantages over
aerobic training and especially when it
comes to improving the number and
efficiency of mitochondria many people
love high-intensity interval training
because it lets them burn calories in a
short space of time and provides the
lorded after burn effect that keeps them
burning more calories even after they
finish training we mustn't over egg this
effect though it's not as profound as
many people seem to think and we mustn't
turn against steady-state cardio
altogether as this can provide many
favourable adaptations when performed
correctly meaning that it should be
truly low intensity that you can't get
from hit not only will it allow for
improvements in technique and efficient
movement with time but it's also
superior when it comes to developing the
size and strength of the heart this
unsurprisingly
is a useful adaptation for a prolonged
endurance there's that sted effect again
but it also lowers the resting heart
rate and improves blood pressure finally
don't forget the other aspects that
contribute to your endurance too that
means things like lung strength and even
the efficiency and economy of your
technique and remember that improving
energy won't just help you in your
training this is something that will
have direct meaningful benefits for your
health and even your brain function and
focus struggling to focus at work feel
tired at the end of the day stop looking
for a silver bullet hack and just get
fitter this will be the ultimate force
multiplier that allows you to do more of
everything and to a higher standard
if you enjoy this comprehensive
philosophical approach to training for
real-world functionality then you might
enjoy my ebook and training program
super functional training this goes into
detail describing how to train different
overlooked aspects of your performance
and ends with a detailed program you can
follow to improve multiple aspects of
your fitness strength speed and focus
you'll find a link in the description
down below and there's a discount on
right now or many of us are still stuck
in lockdown so thanks a ton for watching
this one guys I hope you found the video
useful and interesting if you did please
like and share that helps me out
immensely let me know what your approach
to endurance looks like in the comments
down below of course subscribe to the
channel if you want more like this I
have some really cool stuff on the way
including some exciting announcements I
hope you're all staying safe and healthy
and bye for now